mortal kombat legends battle of the
realms it's a study in contrast it says
too much plot going on but it also has
awesome action ninjas and the voice of
joel mchale here are all the best and
worst things about mortal kombat legends
battle of the realms
johnny cage is a mortal kombat mainstay
going back to the very first entry of
the hit game series he brings to life a
strong hero archetype bravado and a
sense of humor as well looking at the
discussions around his absence on the
recent live-action film and the fans
desires to see him portrayed by the
right actor it all shows how important
he can be to any project in the
franchise joel mchale was a shining part
of the previous mk animated movie
scorpion's revenge and he continues that
streak as one of the best characters in
battle of the realms his relationship
with sonia blade and the levity he
offers is amusing without taking away
from what's going on around him mikhail
has spoken about how he improvised with
his scenes and that may have helped make
some of his moments more genuine and
funnier the only complaint of course is
that cage never secures that big win in
this adventure but he's still a
memorable part of the earth realm
defenders even while being a bit of a
jerk
there are many different realms in the
mortal kombat law several smaller ones
and six primary welds but it's rare that
any others than earth realm outworld and
netherrealm get to play much of a part
in the adventures even in denia where
several characters hail from is usually
relegated to a mention or the tiniest
flashback worlds like chaos realm and
sado are barely mentioned even in the
newer games having become afterthoughts
and the character endings for the most
part this also means that smaller realms
the law has introduced like vague ernest
zotero anyak and architect have little
chance of ever being relevant battle of
the realm still has a story that lives
up to the name but it seems silly now to
have hoped the film would have seen our
heroes go to these places or even give
us new information on them seeing our
champions jump across wells for the
various fights would have been quite the
trees but even on the worlds that were
used there weren't many new details to
be glimpsed even some of the newest
spots from the movie look as if they
were taken directly from the games such
as the shots of chinook's chambers
apparently directly inspired by the
in-game cut scenes from the conquest
mode of mortal kombat armageddon
scorpion's revenge gave fans a wonderful
look at the key parts of shang tsung's
island but the sequel film opened the
battlefield up a bit offering animators
a chance to show off some areas with
which players of the games have become
quite familiar the majority of battle of
the realms takes place in outworld but
beginning portions show off a few
locales on earth brief interludes in
netherrealm the meeting place of the
elder gods and an incredible exercise in
colour toward the end as realms begin to
merge most of these are gorgeous
backgrounds and help bring their
individual parts of the story to life
most notable on earth is a lin kuei
temple a site that has been shown in
different forms before but can never be
explored thoroughly enough the audience
sees a slow long shot of the main
structure the outside courtyard and to
look at the inner sanctum of the grand
master warm radiance containing statues
of famous linguay warriors it all ties
together the foreboding feeling the
scene presents in elsewhere the
participants expressed how intimidating
shao khan's fortresses and a brief
glimpse of his throne room shows off
that awesome green hue behind him there
is a lot of detail put into the arena
where most of the fighting takes place
these are all solid representations of
the stages mostly inspired by the newer
games but the extra bits help make the
worlds feel more alive
one of the awesome things that the last
couple of mortal kombat games did was
progress the overall narrative giving
fans new events and lore to chuwan with
the subject matter for battle of the
realms there was hope that the film
would give us fresh tidbits of lore or
clarify some of the existing meta plot
this isn't just to learn more about the
realms but i hope that fans could see
deeper backgrounds for various
characters or some progression in the
relationships they share none of this
really happens however with the
exception of lu kang which is only a
brief moment that shows the death of his
parents what was that even connected to
and why were those tar cartons on earth
hunting them down those with a truly
extensive knowledge of mortal kombat
could potentially fill in some gaps but
not all of what fans tend to believe is
also considered to be canon so a film
adaptation like this presents an
interesting opportunity to firm up
aspects of the series lore the real miss
prospect here is not providing anything
new about the elder gods the newer
titans or especially the one being who
plays a pivotal role at the end true the
one being is supposed to be a mysterious
figure that no one truly comprehends but
it seems like the writers purposefully
guided the plot around him perhaps so
they wouldn't have to answer any
questions or say something new it's a
shame and it feels like this promising
alternate story though full of passion
falls short of doing anything truly
spectacular
although the last one did a fair job in
delivering on violence and bloodshed
battle of the realms pushed it just a
bit further mortal kombat is a series
that needs to embrace its more vicious
tendencies to feel at home judging by
the creativity in some of these murders
they are loving the recent r ratings
audiences will see some brutal finishes
and a couple of interesting takes on
classic fatalities but a large portion
of the carnage comes from the standard
fighting dispatching grunts in the most
over-the-top way possible not only is
there a ton of decapitations bone
breaking and the ripping out of
perfectly good body parts but the first
act takes advantage of an army of
disposable soldiers we see shots linger
more when some of this happens and much
of the art and animation choices around
these attacks are meant to accent the
savagery each fighter possesses when
pushed this leads to the use of more
x-ray moves that never overstay their
welcome
one of the problems with movies like
this is the desire to throw in as many
extra characters as possible sometimes
because it'll get fans excited to see
one of their low-key favorites but more
often than not they are in there because
the script needed someone to take a loss
or eat a fatality for this instalment it
seems like stryker and jade took that
bullet both are introduced by name get
some lines and do absolutely nothing
else worth mentioning jay's relation to
katana isn't brought up at all and she
gets her skull cracked open by sonia
early on and then knocked off screen
with an impressive uppercut from liu
kang never to be seen again striker at
least gets a little bit more time to
shine he may be the new guy but he's
also a capable hero and he at least
receives a beautifully disgusting death
scene still these are two characters
that feel wasted and would have
benefited from more moments focused on
them scorpion and sub-zero are two of
the most iconic characters in the mortal
kombat franchise but players have a soft
spot for all of the various
pilot-swapped ninja characters from the
games though scorpion's revenge gave us
the classic origin of the iconic ninja
duo fans are excited to see the sequel
bring in cyrax sector smoke and of
course the younger sub-zero kwai liang
who's seeking revenge for his dead
brother these characters are all badass
and each given at least a brief moment
to shine having their own storyline
going on outside other tournaments but
with their robotic arsenals and
elemental powers their fights almost
steal the show that's right the battle
of the realms crams a cyber initiative
story arc into a few spectacular scenes
many of these characters fight together
and against each other giving fans a lot
to observe especially when fighters like
scorpion and sub-zero begin using their
powers together but for many the coolest
bit is getting to see smoke in action
building up the friendship and respect
he has for kwai liang and watching the
story unfold after his change it's hard
not to wish for more of it but their
mission eventually had to feed into the
bigger plot and take the focus off of
those incredibly cool ninja characters
scorpion's revenge had its flaws but
overall it pleased fans and gave them a
reason to believe a sequel would deliver
the goods while battle of the realms
might be an adequate follow-up
especially if only considering the first
two acts something about the ending just
doesn't sit right it isn't horrible but
it's nowhere near the quality of the
rest of the film the third act is much
crazier which is expected but feels like
it's from a different movie
predominantly because of the two main
fights the final battle against shin arc
has a ton of moving parts and is on a
much grander scale with god-like powers
being thrown around this makes sense but
it loses a lot of the intensity not to
mention the blood of the previous
encounters even if the stakes are sky
high no one can call this anticlimactic
a little boring perhaps but there should
be some negative points awarded for only
having a slightly better version of the
ending from mortal kombat annihilation
with the giant dragon and everything the
fight between lukang and xiao khan may
be worse however some of the moves look
like they were lifted directly from
dragon ball z but without the extra
power levels to help it make sense both
of these encounters needed to stay a bit
more grounded to stick the landing
many of the mortal kombat characters
have found their voices over the
lifespan of the series though the actors
who portray them often change even if
what's coming out of the combatant's
mouth might not be a perfect recreation
of recent games none of the voices in
either of the two modern animated movies
have felt bad enough to stand out so
many of the talents who helped bring the
cast to life in scorpion's revenge
return to play the characters again
which is a testament to how well they
did and a great number of the voice
actors filled their parts perfectly with
many of them playing multiple roles it's
always fun to hear words like kami dogu
and outworld uttered with such
seriousness and precision new voices mix
well with the old forming a bloody
chorus of grunts and screams that work
perfectly for the film
animated features are typically shorter
than the live-action counterparts but
battle of the realms clocks in it right
under 90 minutes it's about nine minutes
longer than his predecessor which again
tried to cram too much into his plot and
here it's obvious that wb didn't learn
from their earlier mistake the idea of
not overstaying your welcome is
certainly admirable but why throw so
much into the mix if that's the plan
there's enough platia for two
feature-length projects making matters
even more overstuffed than scorpion's
revenge the champions of earth realm
going to a final tournament in outworld
feels like a plot that easily could have
filled 90 minutes but piled on top of
that it's all the drama of the other
stories too it'd be easy to go trim the
fat saving the kami dogu and the one
being for a follow-up tale when a true
final boss was required however
screenwriter jeremy adams has implied
that the mortal kombat legends films
were a two-chapter story meaning they
had to put everything in because there
might not be others to come if true that
is a huge shame as doing so may have
hindered the overall story and fans
would have likely welcomed further
animated films in the mortal kombat
universe check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]